[Music]
let's see where you've been hiding the
bow failed what motivates the heroes of
sanctuary to battle the forces that
threaten humanity is it an unwavering
desire to do what's right or is it a
thirst for more power more riches and
more stuff whatever it is Reaper of
souls has it this expansion and a decent
new character class a great new campaign
Act and most significantly adventure
mode this new mode is a devious Blizzard
concoction calculated to make Diablo 3's
existing content more rewarding and more
addictive than it has been in the past
the Angel of Death mal fail is the force
threatening humanity in the new campaign
chapter and the impressive opening
cutscene establishes him as a fearsome
adversary indeed showing us why he's
called the Reaper of souls in a bid to
end the conflict between angels and
demons once and for all mal fail is
slaughtering humankind and adding the
dead to his ever-growing armies he's a
terrific and terrifying villain and it's
just too bad that he doesn't show up a
bit more between his showstopping
entrance and the challenging boss battle
that concludes the act your journey to
confront mal fail takes you through the
most grim and beautiful locations Diablo
3 has yet featured absent here is any
hint of the life and color that
sometimes clawed its way into the
settings for the first four acts instead
you explore the gloomy city of Westmarch
on one of the worst nights in its
history later in an impressive moment
you stand atop a massive battering ram
as it smashes open the gates of the
fortress of pandemonium and then venture
into the eerie ethereal realm that lies
beyond if you like your Diablo dark
you'll be pleased to find that act 5
starts that way and stays that way
it's also noticeably tougher than the
axe that preceded throwing more swarms
of monsters at you more frequently
malthael is determined to give your
clicking finger a workout
I'm
Reaper of souls raises the level cap to
70 giving each class new active and
passive skills to unlock playing through
act 5 using my demon hunter I made
frequent use of her new Vengeance skill
which tremendously increases the amount
of damage you deal for 15 seconds and
the expansion introduces a new class the
Crusader a holy warrior who employs a
mix of melee and ranged attacks
crusaders feel weighty and formidable
able to bash foes with shields and cut a
swath through enemies with flails while
also making use of defensive skills to
manage the danger like the ability to
temporarily blind nearby enemies they're
a fine addition to Diablo trees existing
pantheon of powerful heroes but the most
significant addition Reaper of souls
brings to Diablo 3 is Adventure mode
unlocked once you've defeated mal fail
Adventure mode gives you bite-sized
bounties to tackle in every region
across Diablo 3's 5 acts they can get a
great way to accomplish something
meaningful even if you can only play for
15 minutes or so bounties have goals
like killing a specific boss or clearing
a certain dungeon of monsters and they
rewards you with gold experience and a
new item called blood shards usable at
certain merchants completing all 5
bounties in an act
earns you a horrid cache which might
contain some sweet here the best rewards
however come once you collect 5 rift key
stone fragments from doing bounties and
can then open a Nephilim rift these
randomized dungeons are visually
striking for the ways in which they
combine tile sets from familiar
locations with different lighting
effects and conquering one of these
dungeons earns you some quality loot
Diablo 3 is at its core a game about
addiction it tries to keep you coming
back by tempting you with increasingly
alluring rewards with Adventure mode
Diablo 3 now has a way to get bigger
better rewards to you faster than it has
before and if you're not happy with a
particular piece of loot you earn
there's now a new artisan the mystic who
can replace one randomly generated
property on a piece of gear for you it's
a bit of a gamble but you might end up
with something better she can also
change the appearance of your items
you're armored into something that looks
more stylish or making your helm look
like a hood if you've played Diablo 3
before and found that it wasn't for you
the changes Reaper of souls makes to the
game won't be far-reaching enough to
change your mind
Reaper gives those who already likes
Diablo 3 more of what they already like
about it Adventure mode leverages Diablo
3's existing content in a clever way and
with its haunting settings and memorable
villain act 5 is the best chapter in the
game's campaign if you're looking for
reasons to keep on clicking Reaper of
souls has plenty
you
[Music]